auf der jagd nach den geistern teilchen
mit hilfe eines neuen absolut
gigantischen detektor soll in grönland
nach kosmischen neutrinos gefahndet
werden die extrem energiereiche sind
aber doch so wahnsinnig schwer fassbaren
elementarteilchen der nachweis der
geister teilchen soll über schwache
radiowellen erfolgen
ein pionierprojekt dass es so nirgendwo
auf der welt gibt klick zum science im
fußball gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
extrem selten extrem energiereich und
für die wissenschaft extrem spannend
kosmische neutrinos manchmal auch als
geister zeichen bezeichnet und das mit
recht astrophysikerin und astrophysiker
sind diesen besonderen zeichen schon
lange auf der spur
denn mit ihnen lassen sich verborgene
welten erkunden zitat beispielsweise
auch ins innere explodierender sonnen
oder in verschmelzende neutronensterne
woher kein licht zu uns gelangen kann so
beschreibt es die wissenschaftlerin anna
nelles vom deutschen elektronen
synchrotron desy doch den neutrinos auf
die spur zu kommen ist alles andere als
leicht doch die suche könnte jetzt
intensiviert werden mit einem neuartigen
neutrino observatorium in grönland mit
hilfe des so genannten neutrino auf
sorry greenland kurz smo
sie sollen die rätselhaften geister
teilchen über radiowellen detektiert
werden
diese entstehen weil die kollision des
neutrinos eine lawine von sekundär
teilchen verursacht von denen viele
elektrisch geladen sind ihre interaktion
geben radiostrahlung ab die von hoch
sensiblen antennen aufgefangen werden
könnten
der erste radio neutrino detector im
großen maßstab also ein echtes
pionierprojekt doch wie genau
funktioniert diese messmethode und wie
erfolgversprechend ist sie wirklich
neutrinos sind wirklich ziemlich seltsam
entdeckt wurden sie beim radioaktiven
zerfall von atomen
am ende fehlte etwas denn der
verbleibende atomkern und das
ausgesandte elektronen hatten zu wenig
energie es musste noch etwas ausgesandt
worden sein ohne es zu kennen wurde es
neutrino genannt das war anfang der 30er
jahre und erst mehr als
20 jahre später 1956 konnte es
nachgewiesen werden
es sind die häufigsten elementarteilchen
überhaupt wenn sie vorm galaxien und
bewegen das universum sie sind
elektrisch neutral leicht und vor allem
eines mysteriös oft werden sie auch als
geister zeichen bezeichnet denn anstatt
mit materie zu interagieren rasen sie
beispielsweise durch planeten bäume
häuser oder und selbst hier einfach
hindurch in dieser sekunde rasen
milliarden neutrinos durch mich hindurch
und nichts passiert dazu sagt die desi
physikerin an alles neutrinos sind
ultraleichte und extrem scheue
elementarteilchen die teilchen entstehen
in rauen mengen im all vor allem bei
energie reichen prozessen wie kosmischen
teilchen beschleuniger sie sind aber
kaum nachweisbar weil sie so gut wie nie
mit materie reagieren allein von der
sonne durchqueren und pro sekunde rund
60 milliarden - unbemerkt jeden
fingernagelgroßen fleck auf der erde
die masse der neutrinos ist äußerst
gering und für die erkenntnis dass
neutrinos überhaupt eine masse haben
bekamen das entsprechende forschungsteam
vor sechs jahren 2015 den nobelpreis für
physik die geister teilchen die nur
wirklich selten eine wechselwirkung mit
der materie ein
wie wir sie kennen weil sie eben nicht
interagieren rasen sie ungestört durch
spannende messungen gab es in der
vergangenheit vor allem durch das
observatorium namens ice cube das zu
amerikanischen amundsen scott
forschungsstation am südpol gehört 5160
sensoren im antarktischen untergrund
dass in bis zu 2,5 kilometern tiefe die
so zusammen ein riesiges detektor fällt
eine neben cube einen würfel beben die
fachleute konnten beispielsweise schon
spektakuläre beobachtung von und primus
machen die aus dem umfeld eines
schwarzen loches stammen oder aus einem
zerrissenen sternen bereits bei
niedrigen energien der kosmischen
neutrinos schlagen so genannte foto
multiplayer an
die fachleute nehmen mit hilfe des ice
cubes vor allem die sogenannte training
kopf strahlung ins visier
damit ist das leuchten gemeint dass
durch die kollision von neutrinos mit
dem wassermolekülen des eises
konkret geht es um ein schwaches
bläuliches flackern dies wird erzeugt
von energiereichen folge teilchen die
bei einer solchen seltenen neutrino
kollisionen entstehen und die dann durch
unterirdische eis rasen
doch das passiert nicht oft und
schätzungsweise ein paar tausend mal im
jahr aber wenn es passiert dann richtig
pro sekunde prallen zwischen 60 und 100
milliarden neutrinos auf jeden
quadratzentimeter der erde ein
sie stammen aus der sonne oder etwa
gigantischen ereignissen im weltall wie
supernova explosionen oder
gammastrahlenausbrüche und ihre
unfassbare beschleunigung kann man sich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen
in manchen untersuchungen konnten mit
hilfe des ice cubes atoms auch schon
teilchen im bereich von peter
elektronenvolt gemessen werden doch
solche neutrino detektoren die auf fotos
sensoren basieren und die schwachen
freiwerdenden lichtblitze anfangen
sollen haben ein problem
um die seltenen und extrem energiereiche
kosmische neutrinos nachzuweisen sind
die opfer nicht wirklich groß genug also
es gibt viel zu wenig von diesem
neutrinos und in so einem zwar riesigen
großen würfel der ist zu klein um die zu
finden weil sie so selten sind
zudem lassen sich die leuchtsignale der
unterirdischen folge teilchen im eis
nicht soweit verfolgen wie
beispielsweise radiowellen und genau
deswegen wurde jetzt mit dem bau eines
ganz neuartigen observatoriums bekommen
dass die experimente des clubs gut
ergänzen könnte so die große hoffnung
der fachwelt es handelt sich um eine
weltweit einzigartige anlage mit deren
hilfe die jagd nach dem geister teilchen
intensiviert werden soll mittlerweile
wurden für das rating neutrino
observatorien terrain sie bereits die
ersten antennen installiert die neue
messmethode zielt darauf ab die
kosmischen teilchen eben nicht über das
entstehende licht so detektieren sondern
über radiowellen weil man die eben von
viel weiter weg noch finden kann hoch
sensible antennen im eis sind in der
lage diese radiowellen aufzufangen die
durch die kollision der trinos im eis
entstehen zunächst einmal entsteht durch
diese kollision eine lawine von sekundär
teilchen und diese sind elektrisch
geladen die interaktionen sorgen dann am
ende für die radiostrahlung und die
direkt irrt werden soll und rückschlüsse
auf die geister teilchen erlaubt und es
gibt viele vorteile
vergleichsweise weniger antennen
notwendig um größere eisflächen zu
überwachen konkret sind 35 antennen
stationen geplant die in einem abstand
von 125 kilometern auf dem eis
installiert werden soll
das heißt dass mehrere kubikkilometer
volumen beobachtet werden können
der desi physiker christoph welling ist
an diesem spannenden projekt beteiligt
der vorteil von radiowellen ist das eis
für sie ziemlich durchsichtig ist das
heißt wir können radiosignale über
distanzen von einigen kilometern
selektieren energy wird der erste radio
neutrino detector in großem maßstab sein
denn das ist des rätsels lösung wenn man
wirklich sehr große volumina beobachten
kann
dann findet man trotz der seltenen
neutrino kollision dann doch viele und
dabei könnten dann eben auch die sehr
energiereichen dabei seien vorher hatten
kleinere experimente gezeigt dass sich
kosmische teilchen grundsätzlich über
radiowellen nachweisen lassen doch ehe
es soweit ist wird höchstwahrscheinlich
noch etwas zeit vergehen die fachleute
brauchen geduld denn es kann auch gut
sein dass der detektor erst in einigen
monaten oder jahren anschlagen wird
sprich dass diese energiereichen
neutrinos so selten sind dass sie erst
nach monaten oder jahren auftauchen dazu
christopher wellen hoch energetischen
neutrinos lassen sich ungemein selten
auffangen aber wenn man eines erwischt
dann ist der informationsgehalt
unglaublich die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hoffen natürlich sehr
dass sich der bau des observatoriums
auszahlen wird nach seiner
fertigstellung sollen hier tatsächlich
dann mal geister teilchen mit der
riesigen energie von rund 10 milliarden
bis zu 100 millionen elektronenvolt
nachgewiesen werden falls das klappen
sollte wäre das pionierprojekt radio
neutrinos story green energy tatsächlich
eine gute ergänzung zum ice cube am
südpol dieser setzt bei weitaus
niedrigeren energien einreicht aber
dabei nur bis zu wenigen milliarden
elektronenvolt hinauf genau das ist auch
der grund warum die fachwelt so große
hoffnungen in das neue projekt in
grönland eis setzt dazu heißt es vom
beteiligten forschungsteam
je höher die energie desto seltener
werden die neutrinos
das heißt man braucht größere detektoren
die beiden systeme ergänzen sich ideal
das optische als direktor gittern ist
etwa ein bis zu einer neu trainer
energie von einer billiarde
elektronenvolt das radio antenne welt
wird ab rund 10 milliarden bis zu 100
millionen elektronenvolt empfindlich
sein doch noch laufen die ersten
installationsarbeiten und zwar in der
ersten phase noch bis in den august 2021
nein das projekt soll mindestens fünf
jahre bestand haben so der aktuelle plan
falls sich die hoffnungen erfüllen steht
auch schon der nächste step an dann
könnt ihr nämlich ein weiterer radeon
und deckte aufgebaut werden und zwar am
anderen ende der welt dieser könnte dann
ice cube am südpol unterstützen dazu der
desi direktor christian stegmann der
nachweis der radiosignale von hoch
energetischen neutrinos ist ein sehr
vielversprechender weg dem zugänglichen
energiebereich deutlich zu vergrößern
und damit das neue fenster zum kosmos
noch weiter zu öffnen
denn wenn man neutrinos misst kann man
ihre herkunft herausfinden und damit
sehr viel über das universum erfahren
bahnbrechende entdeckung
extraterrestrische quelle der geister
teilchen entdeckt neutrinos da konnte
nämlich zum ersten mal eine quelle genau
detektiert werden was bis dato also
nicht gelungen war also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
mit dem roten button unter jedem video
kostet auch oder auch hier komme auch
draufklicken kostet nichts und macht
schauer ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran